hier mops irgendwie dass man so
plötzlich sofort angst vor hahn muss man
dafür wirklich als ob meine freunde was
geht ab ihr sopran ii und heute spielen
wir ein ründchen ultra hardcore hier auf
dem server und endlich ist mal wieder
eine runde falls dort immer ewig bis die
volle ist weil irgendwie ich glaube die
leute lassen sich nicht so ganz auf den
spielmodus 1
ich hab den hatte ich den ball bereit
vorgestellt ich weiß nicht alt doch da
hatte ich aber so verpackt was jetzt
nicht heißen soll dass im spielmodus
weil ich in variety vorstelle direkt
instant überall famous und bekannt ist
aber ich habe auf jeden fall heute mal
als ziel dass ich eine anständige runde
spiele wo ich nicht so schnell verpacken
wie ich das davor getan habe jetzt habe
ich ein bisschen equipment was am
wichtigsten ist und meine taktik ist
jetzt definitiv erst mal ein bisschen
was essens mäßiges klären also irgend
welche tiere man kann hier alle tiere
töten nicht nur
die die sonst ausgeben auch schafe
trocken hier direkt gebratene steaks und
so was genau hier ist einfach mal zeigen
ja also das ist auf jeden fall da
kriegen wir alles zu fräsen und dann
geht's auch echte hinter die erde weil
bei uns rat cor generiert man ja nicht
dafür muss man gold äpfel essen was sich
immer als ziemlich schwer raus stellt
weil probier mal in zehn minuten gold
führen also kriegs menschen gold für
einen apfel eigentlich und die äpfel zu
kriegen ist ja dann auch kein
kinderspiel
also ich hatte hatte sogar schon mal
gold die letzten runden
die hier so gezockt habe außerhalb der
aufnahme aber dafür hatte ich dann
leider immer technisch mit den äpfeln
und hat nie apple gefunden
bist du natürlich besonders nervig wenn
du keine äpfel hast aber gold okay das
eisen das können wir jetzt verspeisen
für justin sagen würde dann machen wir
das mal acht minuten zeit noch glaubt
bisher sind wir gut in der zeit die
letzte runde war wirklich mega fällig
also hab ich ja nur verkauft aber ich
behaupte mal dass das ein bisschen
besser wird über flugmodus am handy ach
schade ich das wenn er durch die gehöre
hier und wir hatten glück und können
sehr direkt ausruhen
aber anscheinend ist das nicht gefallen
aber bisschen essen noch mitnehmen ist
defintiv nicht falsch und ja das ganze
hat irgendwie auch schon so ein bisschen
wahre charakter und ist jetzt auch immer
öfter im gespräch war wieder war 3 auf
jeden fall riesig lust darauf
klappt der ein oder andere weiß schon
dass schon eine vermutung für mich team
machen werde
wird er natürlich noch mal angekündigt
aber wir können natürlich gerne schon
mal
darüber rätseln und mega cool also
dieses jahr möchte ich echt gut als
wollte ich letztes jahr nicht gewonnen
haben aber dieses jahr möchte ich
wirklich wirklich gut weit kommen und
wehrte auch viel reflektierter seien als
letztes mal
das war mehr so eine entscheidung aus
dem bauch heraus und ich bin zwar im
moment nicht so drin in minecraft und so
aber ich werde noch eine menge
trainieren davor und dann werde ich so
vp wichtig wird sein und dann kommt ja
auch definitiv auf strategie an bei
vario und da werde ich mir auf jeden
fall was gutes einfallen lassen wer weiß
was ich bis war wo alles verändert denn
es könnte alles relativ schnell gehen
denn ich weiß nicht wie viel für euch
schon mitbekommen haben aber ja manche
leute fragen mich auch immer so die neue
abonnieren was so engt dieser name
krankhafter ich frage mich das in
letzter zeit auch immer öfter und bin
deshalb ja der meinung dass ich diesen
namen ändern möchte ok
töte ich den oder nicht ich greife kein
ender männern
ich möchte meinen namen ändern was echt
eine schwere entscheidung ist weil alle
leute kennen mich ja unter dem namen
also ihr wisst jetzt schon mal bescheid
dass ich das vorhabe und wir wie heißen
werde und sonstwas mit iris erst mal
nicht verraten
erfahrt ihr noch früh genug aber ist auf
jeden fall schon mal dass ihr bescheid
wisst falls ihr dann irgendwann mal
jemand anders plötzlich in der startbox
habt dann wundert nicht wer das ist das
nämlich nicht
spox sie ist ja sowieso kein verlass im
moment also fest irgendwann anders mal
jemand anders auf youtube sich besser
gesagt wenn man muss ja auch die certbox
von gestern ich hab mir so viel mühe
gegeben und diese ganzen
diese ganzen szenen rausgeschnitten wo
wir keine runde waren und dann hat
einfach youtube co bugs und deshalb
irgendwie nur die hälfte leute gesehen
die es normalerweise sehen würden das
ist dann schon ein bisschen ärgerlich
aber ja was soll's 526 an wir noch und
noch voller herzen das ist auf jeden
fall was werd ich mache mir da auch
gleich mal einen bogen
aber ich würde sagen es ist ganz gut wir
haben halt begrenzt eisen erst das heißt
wir können nicht so sehr von verstöße
viel davon verspeisen sehr traurig
vielleicht nehme ich ihn einfach mal
sachen mit vielleicht für film
verzauberung tisch sachen dass wir
absolut krass auf jeden fall aber ich
glaube da muss ich mir gar keine
hoffnung machen trübsal
naja versorgungs tisch habe ich habe
auch glaube ich noch niemanden mit
entspannten sachen wir sehen also wenn
du hier irgendwie sowas was reißt so
fundiert entscheiden mäßig dann sind das
bestimmt leute mit mittig spray oder
sonst irgendwelche verbotenen mods hacks
was auch immer ich dachte natürlich
falsch einkriegen
er bitte also ich glaube nicht dass man
hier so auf natürlichem weg außer mit
viel viel glück an so viel an so gutes
equipment kommt hier gibt es kuchen raus
habe ich auch schon versucht er vor
festgestellt aber an sichtbar wäre ich
jetzt gar kein kürbiskuchen sondern ich
will eigentlich noch mal nicht weiter
equippen das wäre ganz angenehm wenn ich
das machen könnte wenn ich einfach
nochmal irgendwie sowas höhenmäßig
finden würde kein glück ja auch nicht
ich weiß nicht was ich mir einfach noch
mal runter bauen
ich glaube das mache ich tatsächlich
gleich nochmal mich runter bauen werde
sie irgendwo in dieser schlucht da vorne
und dann brauche ich mir einfach runter
weil ich meine eisen ist echt so
verdammt wichtig sagen ja auch leitende
nahrungs forscher sagen ja auch du musst
deinen leisten jeden tag du sehr
verspeist
ich glaube der jersak das ist ein sehr
relevanter forscher und seht ihr kaum
sagt man solche war solche weisheiten es
direkt eisen an der decke und wir können
versprechen
okay vielleicht dafür auf jeden fall
sehr lustig ja ich sage nicht was lustig
wird aber es wird auf jeden fall bedarf
geben die gattin chat sprache
abzustellen
bei einem anstehenden projekte und ein
bisschen skelett ich fand es da rein
fliegen lassen
ok ach was mache ich denn jetzt mit
diesen mops da unten oder kemper l lässt
sich einfach durch waschen
ich glaube ich mache mache mir jetzt
einfach mal ne workbench und mache mir
schon mal so weit es geht irgendwie
equipment damit ich falls ich jetzt
getroffen werde
nicht irgendwie großschaden kläger gehen
dann bin ich schon mal gar nicht so
schlecht ausgerüstet und dann ja das
mache ich jetzt noch okay dann bogen
mach ich mir auch noch gehe ich hoffe
mal dass ich jetzt nicht von der seite
disney soll werde von diesem wunderbaren
mops aber das werde ich nicht man muss
wirklich aufpassen er das ist komplett
komisch irgendwie dass man auf solche
solche mops irgendwie das nun also
plötzlich sofort angst vorhanden und man
dafür wirklich als ob lake tahoe comcom
kommt ich war so gut dabei komm schon
das war jetzt aber echt pech dass da so
ein haufen spaß dies auf einmal ist o
komm schon jetzt habe ich vor bei drei
herzen verloren aber es ist auch schon
verdammt ärgerlich es lief so gut davor
wird dann immer ganz ärgert sich so mit
wie viel herz nicht dann ins ins match
kommen bei ultra hat corp aber wir sind
auf jeden fall schon mal gespannt was
unsere gegner sondern es gibt ja auch
ein paar leute die sind richtig gut drin
aber manche sind dann auch einfach nur
mit leder equipment oder sowas
im finale und ein gutes jahr kein großes
finale nicht davor zu sterben schafft
hier eigentlich jeder jemand selbst wenn
man nur mit einem halben herbst aus was
reinkommt dann ist großes pech hat und
irgendwo abstürzt dann wow was ist das
denn mit den kritikern klassisch ultra
hardcore und so aber wir sind ja alle
drei meter creepy ohne spaß aber ich
habe 668 komm schon kann man ja auch mal
ruhe farm oder müssen hier alle zwei
meter irgendwelche tricks macht kommen
was soll ich sagen ich könnte mir einen
tnt machen aber ich weiß nicht wo
verbringen würde
vor allen dingen ich glaube man kommt
nicht an flint weil man kriegt ja immer
direkt
denn hier außerdem kriegt immer instant
pfeiler aus wobei wahrscheinlich ist
einfach entspricht
mein kopf wahrscheinlich entspricht
einfach
der normale gremmel blog lehmann abbaut
den pfeilen und dann gibt's
wahrscheinlich auf dem feld hat hier
auch nur relativ geringe
wahrscheinlichkeit rauskommen oder
vielleicht gibt es ja sogar dann direkt
irgendwie ein feuerzeug oder soll ich
weiß nicht auf jeden fall erschieße ich
gerade meine ganzen pfeile an diese
dummen drei sekunden statt match
gestartet
ok ok dann müssen wir uns jetzt auf
jeden fall beim letzten da ist der
boarder ok haben ein halbes herz gezockt
aber ich musste jetzt ganz schnell los
weil er ein typ ist direkt neben mir
runtergefallen
okay man schwert mit schwert mit schwert
du bist in sicherheit max da vorne ist
der typ der ist aber nicht so gut
geklappt
außerdem kann er natürlich der mit
stilen und dann bin ich ein leichtes
leichtes opfer für die für die anderen
gegner habe ich es verpasst das ding ist
das scoreboard an der seite ist mir ein
bisschen zu groß muss ich sagen dass
nerven bisschen kommt schon mal freuen
wo ist denn hin okay wir können es
einfach anschleichen und er bemerkt uns
gar nicht okay kommt schon der ist ja
noch tier am töten
ein jetzt ein herz ein schuss und der
sound perfekt da haben wir auf jeden
fall ein ohne selbst ein herz schaden zu
passieren ist auf jeden fall eine menge
wert da unten ist ein anderer typ der
hat nur leder equipment
ich werde mir mannheimer machen damit
ich mir hier unten gleich mal ein
bisschen wasser holen kann
falls irgendjemand mit lava kämpft am
besten zweimal falls ich auch lava finde
wollen wir mal das wir ist natürlich
brutal geworden hätte ich den sprung
verkackt aber habe ich ja nicht ok wack
nice den haben wir den andern haben wir
auch zwei es gegeben und es der letzte
der noch lebt also ist es würden würden
easy match für uns ein schuss kriegt er
noch und dann sei da bleibt einfach
stehen
er hat eingesehen dass er verloren hat
ok drei herzen sehen wir uns so richtig
asoziales zu tode jason ok verstärkt na
gut ich kann zwei eine lustige runde auf
jeden fall
ich hoffe euch hast du auch gefallen der
spielmodus kann eine menge spaß macht
und jetzt hatte ich zwar gar nicht so
riesige gegner aber ja schaut doch mal
vorbei
das im stil punkt.de finde ich cool weil
ich will des spielmodus ist ein bisschen
anders
seht schon hier keine einzige lobbyist
falls gerade eben wieder ein kampf bis
sie was voll bekommen habe aber checks
einfach selbst ausmachen bilder von und
dann sehen uns beim nicht mal wieder
macht's gut